make sure you guys hit the Subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and uh
make sure you guys hit the like button
if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and in
all the time that we've been running
this YouTube channel we have never once
explained the character of Batman and I
don't even know if anybody's gonna care
about this so in order to rectify that
mistake over the course of the next 30
minutes I'm gonna make you an expert on
the caved Crusader The Dark Knight
the guy who dresses as a bat and beats
up criminals at night
that dude
so Batman was created by Bob Kane and
Bill finger and first appeared in
Detective Comics Number 27 in 1939 and
the creation of Batman is really a
source of a lot of controversy even
today over eight decades later so the
creation of Batman was inspired by the
success of Superman who had debuted the
previous year which really prompted
National Allied Publications which would
later to become DC Comics to put out a
call for more superhero characters now
here's something that's going to
absolutely blow your mind you're kind of
a sidetracked for a second here's
Something's Gonna blow your mind
National Ally didn't technically become
DC Comics it did but it didn't the way
this works at the time is you had
National Allied Publications which was
the first real accountable company to
exist if we want to call it that shortly
after that you had a company called
All-American Comics All-American Comics
is where you get like Wonder Woman the
original Green Lantern Alan Scott
different things like that eventually
both companies merged and then you got
DC Comics but according to Bill Finger
Bob Kane called him up and then wanted
his opinion on a character that he had
planned to submit called the Batman now
fingers account says that Kane's design
looked very little like the character
that we know today with a sort of Zorro
mask a pair of bat wings red tights no
boots or gloves and fingers says that he
took Kane's idea and made substantial
changes to his aesthetic so that he now
possessed Batman's iconic look including
a full cowl a cape and gloves now Bill
Finger also says that he came up with
Batman's Alter Ego Bruce Wayne by
combining the names of the former
Scottish King Robert the Bruce an
American Founding Father Mad Anthony
Wayne now even though Bob Kane's account
of Batman's creation does note
billfinger's contributions to the
character's designs in the very contract
he signed with national Allied
Publications Kane only arrays for his
name to appear on the credits of every
Batman story and Bill Finger was not
officially recognized as the co-creator
of Batman until 2015 which was over 40
years after his death imagine you
created a character and no one knew that
you were instrumental in that
character's creation until 40 years
after you had passed away now this not
to say that there was never any movement
there had been a movement going on for a
long time to finally get some credit
going there but it just took 40 years
for it to happen now of course as always
when it comes to these videos this goes
into the origin of Batman and Batman's
comic book origin is one of the most
famous in history and has been retold
many times with a few tweaks to the
story along the way but it always boils
down to these elements Batman is
basically a kid named Bruce Wayne who
sees his mommy and his daddy get shot in
an Alleyway in a mugging Gone Wrong by a
guy named Joe Chill and then he
basically decides he doesn't want
anybody else to suffer that same fate
and so he goes to train to become Batman
and then he comes back to Gotham and he
actually makes the city worse by
inciting villains that had no reason to
exist before he became Batman imagine
that you decide you want to fight crime
to make the city better and you actually
make it worse that sucks but after his
original introduction into Detective
Comics Batman received his own solo
title in 1940 with Bill Finger handling
the writing duties and Bob Kane taking
care of the art now during this time
Batman appeared in his signature black
and gray costume and it's actually
during this time that a great deal of
the supporting characters and iconic
parts of Batman's arsenal were
introduced really good example of this
is that Robin is introduced as Batman's
sidekick in Detective Comics issue
number 38 in 1940. now the thing about
this is that Batman's Adventure is up to
that point in time were solo stories
Batman never really had a sidekick or
anything like that and as popular as he
was DC had actually gained the
inspiration for the creation of Robin
from Shazam Billy Batson and the reason
for that is while National Allied had
their own publications of course as with
anything if you find success doing
something people are going to copy it
and so what it did is it led to a
company called fossa Publications which
up to that point just produced magazines
and stuff it led to their president
basically going to Bill Parker and CeCe
Beck and saying give me Superman without
Superman now of course this led to Billy
Batson being created as a kid who met a
guy in a subway station who took him on
a magic train ride and then gave him
Powers creepy story if there ever was
one but Billy Batson could shout the
word Shazam and basically become
Superman and so that's why DC sue the
hell out of fossa Publications took the
character held him for something like 20
years and then eventually brought him
back the popularity of Billy Batson as a
kid who could become a superhero could
not be ignored and so this drove DC to
basically bring in Robin realizing that
having a kid even if he was only a
sidekick was so incredibly popular that
it would actually boost the sales of
Batman's Comics which it did of course
Batman's arch nemesis The Joker was
introduced in April of 1940 and actually
made his first appearance in Batman
number one but the next year the penguin
was introduced to Detective Comics
number 58 and the Scarecrow made his
debut and World's Finest number three
and then of course the year after that
saw the introduction of Two-Face and
Detective Comics issue number 66. now
all of these characters were at least
co-created by Bill finger and Bob King
so it is impossible to overstate the
importance of these two men on the
overall Batman Mythos now Bill finger is
also widely credited with the creation
of most of the iconic accessories and
weapons that have become a part of
Batman's character he created the bat
cave including the famous trophies like
the full-size T-Rex and a giant Penny
and he created the Batmobile now really
the only thing he didn't create were the
batarangs which were actually created by
Gardner Fox who had to write some of the
issues to help with delays on the title
but one of the key differences between
the earliest versions of Batman and the
current one is that at the beginning
Batman did not have a problem with
killing and several criminals met their
demise at his hands I mean quite
literally there's a story where it's
like these escaped maniacs and I think
it's Detective Comics but there's a a
story where these escaped maniacs and
one of them gets hung from the Batmobile
literally Batman hangs the guy from the
Batmobile and he's like he's better off
this way something to know man back in
the 40s back in the Golden Age of comics
they didn't care man heroes would kill
people but the reality here is that
Batman rapidly became one of DC's most
popular superheroes so he was frequently
featured in crossovers with a bunch of
other characters particularly Superman
now Batman Man's first Crossover with
Superman actually came and Superman
issue number 76 and this was a
Monumental event that happened and the
reason why is because up to that point
in time in DC Comics we can just call it
that everybody just kind of existed in
their own little world you didn't really
know if Gotham was on the same Earth as
like Metropolis right if like Superman
was just right over there there was no
way to really know if that was the case
but by having Batman and Superman cross
over it basically created a shared
Universe now we knew that Superman's
just right over there and Wonder Woman
is right over there and it'd be very
easy for these characters to cross over
and in fact they did what's kind of
ironic about this though is that the
initial crossover between Batman and
Superman was a bit of a misnomer so what
you had was a comic called world's
finest who actually had Batman Superman
and Robin on the front cover and the
initial belief is that world's finest
was the first real crossover between
these two characters it wasn't Superman
number 76 in 1952 was the first real
crossover the reason why that comic is
believed to be the case is because of
the cover the but in reality on the
inside it's just a series of individual
stories about Batman and Superman and
they never actually meet but crossovers
between Superman and Batman after issue
number 76 became incredibly common and
in fact team-ups between them usually
appeared in the world's finest comics in
issue number 71 and 1954. but Batman was
also part of the original Justice League
of America which was a team that was
made up of DC's most popular superheroes
and was introduced in 1960 to capitalize
on a Resurgence in the popularity of
superhero comics now one of the reasons
why I want to throw this out here and
this is kind of an important thing to
understand and we'll revisit this over
the course of different DC character
explanation videos that we make is that
by the time World War II came to an end
superheroes weren't popular anymore and
a lot of that was because of the fact
that superheroes gained popularity by
tying into World War II and so it was
like a total war effort right Batman
Superman Wonder Woman they were all
facing off against the Axis powers and
so while you didn't really see members
of the axis leadership named
particularly the message was pretty
clear right you know these superheroes
support the Ally troops and so should
you but by the time World War II ended
people were tired of war and so they
didn't want to read Comics that
literally dealt with superheroes
fighting over in other Wars but because
the popularity of superheroes was born
and bred in war itself when they removed
the wartime element from the comics they
simply just stopped selling now the
other part of this is that in lieu of
people having spent so long focusing on
work they wanted to let their
imaginations go crazy so what they did
is they started focusing on science
fiction that's the reason why you'll
hear about the names of DC writers like
Edmund Hamilton because he was
instrumental in growing the science
fiction genre but the reason this is
important is because in the mid-1950s
what you had was a guy named Julia
Schwartz who basically brought in a
superhero named Barry Allen also known
as a Flash and Barry Allen was the first
time that DC bridged the gap between
superheroes and science fiction even
though he would think superheroes would
inherently be science fiction but Barry
Allen got his powers by literally being
just doused chemicals and struck by
lightning and suddenly he could run at
super speed by whatever man or whatever
means people at that point in time do
differentiated comics and science
fiction they were just two distinctly
different things I don't know but the
thing about it is that the introduction
of Barry Allen just sky
Comics people became way more interested
in it after that than they had been
during about this 10-year lull or so
between the end of World War II and the
time that DC Showcase number four came
out in 1956 but comics in general came
under Fire during the 1950s with a
publication of a book called seduction
of the innocent and the long and short
of this is that some just crazy ass guy
came to the belief that that anything
that he disagreed with was corrupting
America's kids and so what he did was
basically try to get Congress to pass
laws that would restrict what it was
that Communists couldn't talk about but
a lot of parents believe the same thing
like comic books were corrupting kids so
in fact Congress was going to pass
legislation to do that in response the
comic book industry passed its own rules
called the comics code Authority you
guys probably heard of that we've talked
about it before but it was literally
just a governing body with a code of
conduct on what Comics could or could
not cover the reality is that because
Batman's Comics were so dark that he was
by allstanders the measurement of
vigilante taking the Law into his own
hands different things like that and so
this meant that Batman's Comics became a
lot more comical in 1964 to combat
struggling sales Batman was given an
overhaul by artist Carmine infatino at
the request of DC editorial now Batman's
look was entirely updated and the
character returned to really more
grounded detective stories instead of
focusing on outlandish Adventures the
problem with this is that this change
was short-lived the reason for that
being is because the Adam West Batman
show was basically predicated on the
Batman comics as they've been created
during the era when the comics code
Authority had the most control over what
DC could publish so by the time DC
wanted to put Batman back to his more
grounded and semi-violent detective
Roots people actually rejected it
because they loved the show with Adam
West and they wanted to see that show
reflected in the comics but in 1969 the
tone of the character just completely
shifted yet again when we ended up
getting Dennis O'Neil and Neil Adams who
came on as writer and artist now the
thing about this is that Dennis O'Neil
and Neil Adams their run is landmark in
fact whenever Neil Adams would go to a
Comic-Con he would literally just be
surrounded by the entire Omnibus run of
his works as Batman but the thing about
this is they had made their bones with
like Green Arrow Green Lantern
particularly the story snowbirds don't
fly which is when you basically learned
that Green Arrow sidekick Speedy was
essentially using heroin which flew in
the face of everything the Communist
code Authority stood for and in fact was
one of the early stories that actually
began to eat away and chip away at the
role that kindness code Authority played
because people were starting to buy DC
Comics whether or not they had the seal
of approval from the comet's code on
them but the reality here is that
O'Neill and Adams made this deliberate
effort to essentially remove the campy
elements from Batman stories and really
recapture the old Bill finger in Bob
Kane original version of the character
that had a gritty detective feel to it
and in fact this run has become
incredibly influential to the character
and is legendary with fans but sales of
Batman's title continue to fall
throughout the 1970s and the 1980s
completely bottoming out in 1985. now
this led to one of the single most
important decisions that DC would ever
make for the character of Batman and in
fact had they not made this story we
would not have Batman comics so the
thing about this is that at the time
when Batman's sales were just slumping
there was a guy over at Marvel Comics
who was writing Daredevil comics and
setting the world on fire and this guy's
name was Frank Miller I'm sure tons of
you guys already predicted that and the
thing behind this is that Frank Miller's
writing style was just visceral and it
just hit you in all the right ways and
so what DC did in 1985 is they launched
crisis on infinite Earth because in
addition to Batman's comic struggling
what you had was just the overly
complicated nature of the Multiverse you
had prices on Earth one you had crisis
on Earth two you had all these crisis
events where I release those those two
real prices events but you had different
versions of characters from across the
Multiverse so it was just ridiculously
difficult for somebody who had never
read a comic once in their life to walk
into a comic book store in 1979 and tell
somebody they wanted to read Batman and
to know exactly how it all fit in
continuity it was an unmitigated mess
all thanks to the flash of Two Worlds
story back in the 60s which introduced
the Multiverse to DC Comics and so
because Batman's sales were struggling
and because crisis unoffended Earth was
going to reboot the entirety of the
Multiverse and in a lot of ways give DC
Comics a fresh start DC editorial was
considering canceling Batman and so what
they said is we're gonna give this guy
one shot right we're gonna create a
single Batman comic and we're gonna see
how it performs we're gonna give it to
Frank Miller if this guy is just popular
as he is if he can't sell Batman comics
no one can and so they gave Frank Miller
Batman and they said just give us a
story we don't care what you do just
give us a story and Frank Miller wrote
Dark Knight Returns one of the single
greatest Batman stories to ever be told
and in fact the story that saved Batman
from cancellation and so Frank Miller
followed up The Dark Knight Returns with
a retelling of Batman's early days in
Batman year One which basically tells
the story of Batman's return to Gotham
after having been away for 12 years and
basically training but it also happens
to be the first year in Gotham for
commissioner Gordon as well and this was
another insanely well received Batman
story from Frank Miller and really
cemented his place as perhaps the most
influential writer on the character
except for Bill Finger himself and in
fact Frank Miller would write the
character a few more times with the Dark
Knight strikes again in 2002 All-Star
Batman and Robin the Boy Wonder in 2005
and The Dark Knight 3 Master race in
2015 but in addition to like delays and
all that kind of stuff a lot of people
just found pretty much all the stories
regarding Batman that Frank Miller wrote
After the Dark Knight Returns in year
one to just not be all that great
foreign
they were rough but regardless of how
Frank Miller's later work had been
received the reality is of the work that
he had done was just Landmark and it
quite literally not only saved Batman
but because Batman defeated Superman and
Superman had his own host of issues on
the polling side with Julia Schwartz and
sand Superman and all that kind of stuff
they basically led to Batman overtaking
Superman in popularity and so the 1990s
brought a new era of over-the-top
muscles and like Ultra Modern costumes
to comic books in general and Batman was
no exception the biggest example of this
came during the 1993 storyline Nightfall
which actually introduced Bane to
Batman's Rose gallery and then just
super elevated him to the top of like
Batman's most dangerous foes because the
Nightfall story arc literally saw Bane
breaking Batman's back after deducing
his identity having only been there for
three months Bane was a hoss when he was
first introduced nowadays he kind of
sucks so back then he was really really
amazing but of course the paralyzing of
Batman at the hands of Bane saw Azrael
essentially taking over and he was a far
more edgier and a more brutal version of
Batman until of course Bruce Wayne
returned to reach take the mantle but of
course what really helped to solidify
the Batman comics and basically
continuing to grow in popularity was
stuff like Batman in 1989 by Tim Burton
and like Batman the Animated Series by
Bruce Tim and Paul dini Batman mask of
the Phantasm which is still the greatest
Batman movie ever made I don't care what
anybody says but the fact that a lot of
people were watching these TV shows or
these films or what have you and then
learning about the character for the
first time it resonated with him and the
fact that they went to go read the comic
switch for the most part lined up with
what they saw kept them reading the
comics and that's how DC ended up with
lifelong fans but the other big run on
Batman comics that should really be
mentioned here during this point in time
is Grant Morrison's run in the mid-2000s
which is still considered one of the
best Batman runs by a lot of different
fans and there were really two big
developments of the character that came
from Morrison's time and writing the
first was the introduction of Damien
Wayne who's the son of Bruce Wayne and
Talia al Ghul who will go on to become
the fourth version of Robin now of
course Damien is still a huge part of
Batman's Supporting Cast and is really a
divisive character but watching Batman
come to terms with being a father added
a whole new element to the character
that hadn't really been seen before but
of course the apparent death of Bruce
Wayne that happened during the events of
final crisis was another major thing for
his character because the effects spill
over into Batman as Dick Grayson the
original Robin ends up taking up the
mantle of Batman with Damian Wayne as is
Robin now of course Bruce Wayne was not
actually dead during the events of final
crisis because he was just too popular
to kill which is really his major power
I mean let's be honest with ourselves
the real superpower of Batman is that
he's too popular to cancel and so
ultimately he ended up returning in a
story aptly titled the return of Bruce
Wayne ended up back in the modern era
Richard the mantle of Batman from Dick
Grayson and has just kind of been around
ever since but while there were a lot of
different stories he being told about
Batman in the 2000s that we really just
haven't mentioned here I would say
probably the next significant moment for
the characters publication history came
with DC's New 52 reboot in 2011. now
this popularity with Batman came from a
couple different reasons the first was
because DC's New 52 just total reworking
of their landscape was highly publicized
I mean it was a great big huge marketing
Blitz that DC put on right have you
never read DC Comics before great Now's
the Time to get on and it worked
specifically for the character of Batman
and a lot of this was because of the
fact that Scott Snyder was the guy who
was writing when Scott Snyder took over
the title of Batman I mean he blew the
doors off right like he literally came
out guns blazing with his story the
court of owls now the reason why this
story was so significant is because
Scott Snyder and gregapullo's run did
not drastically alter the character but
was extremely popular with readers and
did introduce a major addition to
Batman's Rose Gallery with the court of
owls themselves which was basically a
secret society of criminals that had
been operating in Gotham them ever since
the city's founding now the beauty of
this story is that it did not treat it
as some kind of MacGuffin or some kind
of nonsensical thing it was written in a
way to where it was believable that the
court was so incredibly secretive that
the world's greatest detective didn't
know they were operating right under his
nose but the writing style of Scott
Snyder and the Artistry of Greg capulo
just captivated fans and it was hugely
popular but one of the big things that
you saw when it came to their run as
well was the highly publicized Return of
the Joker and death of the family and
Batman in game both of which were just
massively popular stories and this right
here is what solidified and made
Batman's run during the New 52 so
phenomenal with fans but in addition to
having a high selling and exceedingly
loved solo title The New 52 further
cemented Batman's place as a pillar of
the DC Universe and that he was a
founding member of the new 52 version of
the Justice League by Jeff Johns and
played a prominent role in that book
throughout its entire higher run and in
fact Batman was also at the center of
several crossovers that spread across
multiple titles as DC tried to use his
popularity to improve the sales of other
titles and in addition to the regular
monthly titles that featured Batman DC
launched two different weekly series
centered around him as well because it
became obvious that Batman sold books
and DC intended to milk his popularity
for all it was worth in a trend that is
continued in DC to this day however
there were some issues where I'm not
paying this picture to Batman's Comics
at the time were absolutely perfect one
of the bigger problems that you had here
is that when DC launched the new 52 and
we picked up with Batman the explanation
is those characters had only been around
for five years so it had been five years
between the time that Bruce Wayne had
essentially first arrived in Gotham City
and when we saw him as Batman as we knew
him now this came this kind of
explanation of how he became Batman was
actually explained in a story called
zero year by Scott Snyder it was a
three-part story it was absolutely
wonderful but what fans had hard time
accepting is that when characters like
Bane were introduced or when things like
the death of Jason Todd who was Robin at
the hands of the Joker was still a thing
in his continuity that all of that was
expected to have happened in five years
that within the span of five years Jason
Todd had been killed by The Joker that
Bane had broke Batman's back just all
those things fans had an exceedingly
difficult time swallowing that pill and
it seemed just really silly but the
reality was it's popular as his Comics
were while there were grumbles and
gripings about those kinds of things the
writing of Scott Snyder gray capullo
basically led to a lot of fans to just
kind of sweep that little tidbit under
the rug and just focus on how great the
stories were ignoring a lot of the major
continuity errors that existed and so in
2016 DC relaunched its entire line of
comics and while they did not reboot
their continuity as they had with the
new 52 all of their titles were
basically given new creative teams
including Batman now this led to one of
the more divisive eras of Batman's
writing because when Scott Snyder left
the title it led to a guy named Tom King
coming on and basically taking his place
now the reality is that as soon as Tom
King came on he announced that his run
would actually total 100 issues although
it was received with a pretty lukewarm
reception and in fact his highly
anticipated 100 issue run was actually
shortened to the longest 85 issue run
I've ever read in my life
it did have cool stories don't get me
wrong it did have some cool stories I am
Gotham I am Bane different things like
that those were just great stories right
the war of jokes and riddles phenomenal
stories I absolutely love those it was
everything in between
that just dragged on the reality here if
I'm kind of injecting my own opinion the
reality here is that Tom King's entire
Batman run just really felt like him
patting himself on the back and it was
like a love letter to himself right it
was almost him just kind of getting full
on what it was that he was doing and
it just didn't feel as great as it could
have been and in reality I wasn't really
alone and feeling this but a big reason
for the fan disappointment in Tom King's
run was that the runs seemed poised to
deliver just this huge change to Batman
status quo because there were a bunch of
issues that led up to a promised
marriage between Batman and Catwoman
which was set to take place in issue
number 50 and I I kid you not but I kid
you not what this guy did and I don't
know if it was DC editorial I don't know
if it was Tom King it was the biggest
gotcha like that's literally what it was
the biggest moment like that ever
everybody was looking forward to the
people who were reading Tom King's run
were like yes right Batman and Catwoman
are finally gonna get married they've
been docking the boots for God only
knows how long they've been doing
everything but being married the writing
between the two of them in terms of how
they talked was a little weird but we
were all excited for it and then
literally Catwoman's like you you know
you there has to be a Batman and if you
marry me then you know there won't
really be a Batman anymore or something
like that and then she just bailed on
him she literally left him at the altar
and the two of them never got married
and so the result of this is that a lot
of people including myself felt like it
was just a giant bait and switch that it
was a way for DC to kind of build up
this event that was gonna happen and
like you got to read the story so you
know what's going on and nepher actually
had any intention of having Batman and
Catwoman get married people felt tricked
it was like a smaller more scaled down
version of The Death of Superman in the
1990s when DC was like Superman's gonna
die guys so you gotta you know it's
gonna be a great big huge thing he's
gonna be dead and gone he's never gonna
come back and then they brought him back
and people felt tricked they felt like
his death didn't mean anything and the
sales of Action Comics never recovered
but people felt like that with the
Batman run by Tom King what this did is
it led to just this catastrophic
drop-off of the stories and people
stopped reading Tom King's Batman after
that but 2017 uh basically saw the
ending of the DC rebirth initiative
right that's when the whole thing
basically began to wrap up and the
reality here is that Batman's character
is still evolving and it is still
changing right he's still kind of having
a few things thrown in and so on and so
forth you know and then again there's
some of the things that we didn't talk
about that are still having effects to
this day for example Batman Incorporated
that one of the things that Batman had
done during Brent Morrison's run is he
has actually traveled around the world
and essentially created a Batman team in
different places around the world a lot
of those effects are still being felt
right now there's things like ghost
maker who's basically somebody that
Bruce Wayne had trained with in his
younger years that initially started off
as a sort of friendly rivalry but ghost
maker was a lot more intense than Batman
was but Tom King's run is really the
last complete run for Batman that we saw
there were some things that were done in
DC's future state which I kind of read a
little bit but ultimately ended up
bailing out on but as always again his
character is changing and evolving but
with that being said guys let me know
what you think about this new video
format for character explanations
honestly I love it I think it's really
really cool but let me know what you
guys think thank you all for watching
and I will catch you all later
peace